uh cricket today committed to taking
white at live to the oval in south
london for a statement from the england
and wales qriket board promotes
inclusion and diversity at all levels
we committed to tangible action and
discussed several areas of focus
including stamping out discrimination
making cricket more open and inclusive
and ensuring effective governance and
leadership
the group worked through a series of
actions
that aim to tackle the serious questions
that have been brought
up over the last few weeks each
individually agreed to consult with
their respective stakeholders
to come together as a game next week and
publish further details
we'd like to make the following
statement as well
the ecb the mcc the pca nwca and first
class and recreational county cricket
said the following
azim rafiq has shown a light
on our game that has shocked
shamed and saddened us all
racism and discrimination
is a blight on our game
to reseme and all of those who have
suffered or experienced any form of
discrimination in our sport we are truly
sorry
our sport did not welcome you
our game did not accept you
as we should have done
we apologize unreservedly for the
suffering you have faced
we stand together against discrimination
at all levels
and in all its forms and we are united
as a sport
to do whatever it takes
to eradicate
the scourge from our game
we will continue to listen to make swift
and positive change to the culture of
the game
we will embrace and celebrate
differences
everywhere
knowing that with diversity we are
stronger
today is a game we discussed a series of
tangible commitments to make cricket a
sport where everyone feels safe and
everyone is included
we will now finalize the detail
and publish these actions next week
our game must win back your trust